zach davies comes out to hit the tricky
by run bmc off the album raising hell i
know you had it back in the day cubs and
the pirates first of three
and the 28 year old from gilbert arizona
on the mound davies turns kicks fire
and that one hit on a bounce gobbled up
by the gold glover and rizzo will take
it himself
in the air out towards left field
jack peterson
baby's ready to work
and a good change up to strike him out
gonzalez is gone and zach gets him one
two three kale's had a little bit of a
roller coaster type season he's been
good he's been bad he's been good he's
been bad it's almost been exactly like
that he's a guy that's got to figure out
what he has on certain days he plays off
that singer's ground ball rate is very
high
and jack peterson into left field
weekly hit toward third there's todd
frazier one play to first
peterson to second
bounce to short and again not where
cahill and stallings wanted it but it
produces an out save for third is
peterson now there are two out for
anthony rizzo
of the year down the line right side
evans
that's fair ball that's a fair ball
indeed peterson
into score rizzo down to second
all the wind the sky the wall they all
present problems for an outfielder in
this ballpark
high chop
and that is gonzales onto first and in
the dirt moran digs it out and so an
unearned run against cahill it's one
nothing
here comes
up the middle through his legs and
diving frazier can't get it trickles
into center and it's a base hit for
bodhi
bend it first davies up here
pushes the butt first base side it's a
good one cahill up with it under hands
to first and body into scoring position
peterson single to left and scored the
game's only run in the first inning 2-2
that one fisted into right field that's
a base hit racing around third coming in
to score boaty he's in there jack's got
his second hit of the day and the cubs
lead two-nothing
jack peterson starting to get it going
cahill will get the strikeout of bryant
but the cubs pick up another and through
two have a two-nothing lead
here's the o2 and it hit him in the hip
the right hip as he was turning away it
hit him right near that belt buckle well
he finds his way on again but a
painfully
and this ball oh look at this trevor
kell on his way to the bag you see the
fist bump the pump of the fist knowing
he was going to get a hit
that's for this okay yeah
turned into a baseball factory
rizzo 2 is right up with it over to
davies and he gets out of the inning
left side gonzalez
beats it out in field single for javi
nobody else does that right ripped to
the right field base hit rizzo hit it
hard
baez to second
and two on and nobody out
gets the whiff
he did that now he took a chance and
threw an edge pitch actually it
could have been ball four
i would really try to pound this ball to
right center field if you're duffy
in the air center field see what happens
reynolds catches it baez here's the
throw and he scores
matt duffy delivers there's a ball in
play for a sac fly and it is
three-nothing
and the infield hits started it here
listening swinging a fly ball he broke
his bat out toward the mound it'll be
the third baseman todd frazier to retire
it and the inning is through a run on
two hits
on the ground
dives nice play babies gets over
great play by anthony the dancing bear
does it again and steams this throw over
to davies
the 1-0
on the ground but right at duffy edge of
the grass
[Music]
[Applause]
in the air center field brian
coming on coming on coming in makes the
catch
there's work zach davies
the one-two
blind and the base hit it to left field
how about bodhi he's two for two
oh yeah there's there's little things
yep
and there's a play made by frazier and
that is turned into two that worked
that's the opposite of what we were
talking about good d 4-6-3
1-1 is rope to left peterson on the run
can't get their base hit he'll play it
on a hop and stallings with the pirates
first swinging hit today man at first
the pitch
is hit on the ground to short
they get one
and they turn it well done
baez to body to rizzo six four three and
there are two outs it's three nothing
coast
that one line base headed to left field
and bryant is aboard
ripped into left field that's a base hit
a rocket off the bat of baez
[Applause]
bounce to second
one
two
that was a huge help right there
rolled over and threw into the right
side base hit
adam frazier with a one out single to
right
chopped on the ground out to short byans
picks it up throw to first
single and ready to make
we might have an infield hit we will not
get anybody out on that one
colin moran
add that to the list of opposite field
hits for him
another hard hit ball and this time a
base hit for evans to abort here we go
now you got your opportunity tying run
at the plate he did hit kai tom now he
walked stallings to load him up oh man
just he just threw the door open right
there
back to the mound
and the one two three double play
love you lawrence well
that's ripped to right field and a base
hit and that is the third hit of the day
for jack peterson good to see his man at
first 3-0 and they got him
[Applause]
now peterson in the pickle
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
peterson and the tag put on him
and that'll end the inning
i thought he had the invisibility cloak
on i think i think absolutely
here's the pitch
a swing of the ground ball slowly hit
and through it gets past bodhi
and into center for a base hit so it
just kept going pitching change david
ross wants to bring in ryan tapara to
two now to para deals
[Applause]
and hayward that ball is going to drop
and bounce over the wall that ball kept
carrying it looked as though hayward or
brian had a beat on it but pirates in
business now second and third
stallings doubles
and bounces it to short
pirates get one but
more importantly for the cubs they get
the second out two outs three to one and
it's all up to kai tom
and the center field kai tom
makes it a one-run game
and now
he is the tying run on and wilmer defoe
will pinch hit david ross is going to
bring in rex brothers
and a pop up to shallow center and it is
gonna drop in
pirate's still alive
and in fact 90 feet away is the tying
run in ka'i tom
oh he's hit
and the bases are loaded 3-2 cubs lead
in the 90.
brothers is ready here it comes
in the air towards right this should do
it hayward couple steps in he's got it
ball game
cubs win
four in a row for the cubs as they hang
on here today
3-2 the bottom never doubt